hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
the target demographic for the
Chromebook pixel to people who are
expected to buy it as a percentage of
the normal population is almost nothing
but that's okay this is a Chromebook
pixel 2ls and apparently LS stands for
ludicrous speed and I believe it it has
the specs that look way too ridiculous
to belong in any Chromebook and I wasn't
originally going to do a video about it
but after actually using it for a while
I have to at least show it to you guys
because I like it too much not to
basically I'm guilty of falling in love
with an incredible piece of hardware
even if it does have a pretty narrow
functionality so on the outside it's
pretty simple it's an all-metal design
nearly the same as last year and a bunch
of little tweaks are made to make this
version better than that
so it's weighted pretty much perfectly
as a laptop so you can lift the hinge
without the bottom of the laptop moving
so that's a nice touch and it has a
slightly new keyboard design so all the
special keys up top that it functions
inside Google Chrome are now a little
bit lower so they feel like part of the
rest of the keyboard and this is
actually a really nice keyboard it has a
decent amount of travel and it's a
pleasure to type on for long periods of
time because that's exactly what I did
and the trackpad is also new it has
built-in gestures now kind of like OS 10
so you can use a four finger swipe to
reveal all of your open chrome windows
which kind of feels like real
multitasking when you have a bunch of
apps open and of course you can't forget
where it got its name the Chromebook
pixel has an incredible display again
very bright very vivid very contrast the
awesome viewing angles and 2560 by
1700's so some extra vertical pixels for
web browsing and web apps since
everything Scrolls vertically anyway and
it's still an awesome touchscreen too
and because of these awesome specs it's
actually really smooth like very
impressive kinetic scrolling felt iPad
like on this massive display I mean I
was very impressed using it and then of
course there is new ports so the
Chromebook pixel switched out its old
charger for a USB C port and not one but
two so one on either
side so on one side you have a USBC port
and a full-size SD card reader so
there's your expandable storage and on
the other side another USB C port so yes
you can plug in to either side and as a
backup you also get two full-size USB
ports and the headphone jack so I mean
with this combination of specs and build
and ports and price and everything
honestly this would make an awesome
Windows machine or Mac laptop before you
even find out it runs Chrome OS so
that's also neat there's also a pretty
dope LED light strip up top and that has
some new features too now so it lights
up all colors when your laptop is on
which i think is pretty nice it was
yellow only in last year's and then
there's this knock feature which is
probably heard about when the laptop is
closed you can just knock three times
and it'll light up with the amount of
battery life you have left which is
really cool and when you plug in it
tells you how close you are to done
charging that's a nice way around the
USBC charger not having an indicator
light the absolute worst part of the
Chromebook pixel hardware is a toss-up
between either the speakers this time or
the camera the camera is just this
garbage 720p webcam wasn't expecting to
be impressed with it but hey at least I
can say it's not 480p em and the
speakers are actually underneath the
keyboard so there are no speaker girls
or anything it just kind of sounds like
the sound is being muffled by the
keyboard because it is but outside of
those two things you know performance is
extremely good all the time
battery life is extremely good you can
get 10 plus hours of use every single
day and the apps you get from the Chrome
Web Store
look it doesn't do much but what it does
do it does very well the Chrome Web
Store is a lot more full-featured now
than it was last year when I showed it
and you can now sort by apps that are
just links to websites versus actually
fully built web apps which are much
better and you can also run apps that
were built for Android on this thing too
so you can legitimately get a lot done
in this newest version of Chrome OS now
if you've gotten this far and you're
still thinking dude why would I want to
pay over $1000 for a web browser I could
get way more for less money then this is
definitely not for you but for those who
can get away with using mostly web apps
which have gotten really good and maybe
having a cheap Windows machine on the
side for when you need something that's
not available online this is a beast of
a machine the one thing I'd like to
change
since Wi-Fi and internet isn't available
everywhere I would like to see this
laptop with LTE so I could have Internet
on-the-go
that would be pretty damn close to my
perfect ultra portable so that is the
story there for the Chromebook pixel -
it is like the original a beautiful
piece of engineering and an incredible
piece of hardware that you should
probably never buy well I mean you can
buy it but you should know what you're
getting yourself into first
they have it thanks for watching if you
enjoyed it feel free to hit that thumbs
up button below and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace